right here we go
okay I bet you love Lunchables I'm
excited about that yeah because I bet
you love building them and popping them
in your mouth like this talk me through
it what are you doing uh I've got meat
cheese meat and I'm gonna go cheese
again but I'm gonna put the cheese at a
different angle
open in one oh my God is that a bad is
that mistake it's the driest thing I've
ever tasted them
that is I mean I'm trying to pick one up
and it's just shattered in my hand that
is insane yeah the cracker is letting
the team down not very bad
buongiorno
you want to tug that yes thank you
okay
why did we suddenly turn into like
gangsters
with that Bible man I mean let's do that
interview